there were six critical years that saw
Lebanon nearly descend into a failed
state
president Michelle Hound's tenure has
come to an end but he's promising to
continue the fight against corruption
within what he describes as the ruling
establishment
the biggest Financial crime committed in
the world using your own money we could
have cut the losses by using Capital
controls to prevent money smugly
something that still hasn't happened why
they're challenging us is it because
they're going to be prosecutions
[Music]
just like the last two presidencies
Parliament has not approved a
replacement for round plunging the
country once again into crisis and
creating a power vacuum
aung says he's also approving the
government's resignation
I think we're very familiar with this
these vacuums this is not the first time
as you know that we Face such a vacuum
it's more of a tradition now in Lebanon
nevertheless I think this is
representative of the inability of the
current Lebanese Constitution its
inability to function properly
the president left surrounded by his
supporters who came to accompany him on
his trip from the presidential Palace to
his new residence
[Applause]
this is our s is our second departure
from the presidential Palace in three
decades the feds saw him leaving
defeated as the Lebanese civil war came
to an end in 1990. now he leaves behind
a better Legacy that many Lebanese will
remember his presidency for
some analysts believe that challenges
facing Lebanon began long before Hound
came to office
owns presidency should be thought of as
part of a Continuum
what we're currently living in Lebanon
is
um is a continuity of a path that has
been unraveling for the past
um
not just 10 years or 11 years some would
even extend this uh continue until the
1990s out to the Christian came to power
in 2016 endorsed by Hezbollah in a
political deal that brought back Sunni
politicians prime minister many Lebanese
will likely remember the Hound era as a
time of great difficulties
the biggest one being the 2020 Beirut
Port explosion that killed hundreds the
investigation into the cause went
nowhere with various political factions
exerting pressure on the Judiciary to
limit the scope of the inquiry
that was followed by the significant
loss of value in the nation's currency
which has led to a mere total Financial
collapse and people unable to withdraw
their money
Lebanon will now await the election of a
new president in the coming weeks but
it's not only about political factions
agreeing on a candidate it's also about
Regional players facilitating and
supporting such a move now though
Despite All the Troubles many Lebanese
will hope to see a more stable future
and an end to their troubles foreign